Well,
I'm a philosopher,
so I was thinking of soldiers in terms
of there's the meaning and philosophical
meaning of their stories,
the emotions and the deep emotions.
And I interviewed a lot of soldiers,
probably about 30 to 40 soldiers,
so the current wars and including some
from Bosnia and Vietnam and my dad who's
a World War II veteran and I really
wanted to go beyond just stories about
trauma of which many soldiers don't
suffer though,
of course we know many do,
but I wanted to talk about the feelings
everyone seems to come home with,
of trying to make moral sense of what
they've seen and done.
Um,
even when they do everything right by
wars,
best standards.
So it was talking about the,
the moral weight of war,
memorial burdens of war.
Well,
my dad actually just died,
um,
December 15th that the days I was
putting the final touches on the book
and I always knew he was a world war two
veteran and a medic.
He never fired a rifle a gun during the
war,
but always had this sense that war was
hell.
And he didn't want to talk about it like
many of his generation,
a member of a laconic generation.
And um,
when he died I was cleaning up as
affects and found in his pockets,
his dog tags and um,
he never told me and I never asked.
And so it was 65 years of carrying his
dog tags.
Um,
they were an identity to be sure,
but they're also a moral identity or
moral burden.
And I thought he really carried it
silently.
He thought it wasn't polite conversation
to talk about the war.
When I probed,
you know,
he would say,
well aboard the Qe one,
the Queen Elizabeth,
the first and the Queen Mary,
it was a slaughter house.
It was a butcher shop,
was amputated legs and men that were
really,
really suffering,
um,
this one will have a leg in that one,
Walt.
And so it was painful.
Tears would come down and I realized he
never wanted to watch footage of the war
and he wasn't traumatized,
I don't think is very healthy,
resilient guy.
But if his war was difficult,
it was so,
for many.
And I don't think war should be a
private burden,
um,
whether it's a draft war or a volunteer
force or your guard national guard or,
or you know,
a member.
Well,
contractors are,
no history is complicated story,
but go,
going out.
I'm going out to war part of the
reserves.
So he was,
I think the,
the,
the unconscious reason you might say.
I also have an uncle who fought in world
war two as a marine
bayonet,
Oka Allah,
really ugly.
And he did suffer ptsd,
posttraumatic stress disorder.
But the book isn't really about,
about psychological injuries that we
know about that are very acute.
It's about the everyday ordinary mix of
feeling exultant about the battle and
exuberant and that it's your,
the time of your life to,
to shine for some and that that's the
only way that you could go in and be a
sniper who's defending himself and his
buddies and to,
you know,
for,
for victory or survival.
And then also feeling the shame of,
of doing what you do when you do it.
All right.